hey everyone I'm scratching my nose okay
Justice League has arrived we've all
seen it we have some thoughts on it our
own reactions and reviews but also given
the mixed reactions in the press our
critics being completely fair to it well
we'll get to that this is the need to
know a weekly deep dive into all the
biggest news this week but really guys
Justice League is the biggest story
right now so we're just gonna spend
pretty much this entire episode talking
about it we're also gonna check in with
you guys on Stardust just click on our
starters download link in the
description below so you can upload your
reactions to your favorite movies and TV
shows tag us at new rockstars get them
featured on the show by the way I'm Erik
Bosse and the rest of these Superfriends
are hey over here is Sam basher over
there and I'm Tommy Bechtold and these
are my parents now you're no son to me
thanks dad all right well obviously our
top story is our review of the Justice
League but I wanted to lead with this
Stardust reaction from none other than
our good friend mr. Sam - all right I'm
getting out of the theater guys I'm
gonna be honest I hated that maybe
Superman hated Suicide Squad garbage
movies I'm being honest Justice League
good amazing I honestly don't know what
the critics are talking about it was
lovely
is it flawed of course it's like I could
give it a P Plus maybe a - I loved it
great flash great Batman great Wonder
Woman
Aquaman Superman everybody let me know
what you thought tag me in it so I'm
just gonna filthy mouth I had opinions
and feelings I just want to leave you
like like that for the whole show this
is a memory of you but you're here - hey
lowered a little bit but no I mean still
and we'll get into that right yeah
whatever your opinions are on this film
Sam does I think bring up a good point
that the critics almost seem predisposed
to hate this movie yeah it's almost like
these days critics don't even review the
movie itself they just review them
of surrounding the film I think more
than anything critics just don't want to
be on the wrong side of history they
want to agree with that consensus but
with a movie like Justice League it
seems like the narrative is oh the DCU
is trying to copy Marvel's Avengers
strategy without earning it with solo
films or Zack Snyder is pretty much
style over substance with Man of Steel
and Batman for Superman looks like he's
going to send me here or oh so I tried
to step down my production now Joss
Whedon can he save the day by the way
really quick we know too much about the
production of this movie right we know
way too much about has become the story
unlike the story of the movie itself and
all that stuff it makes her a good press
I just don't know if it's really fair to
let that bias our perception of the
movie personally I think that by has led
to critics being too kind to movies like
Wonder Woman Thor Ragnarok press was in
love with newcomer directors like patty
Jenkins at ICO with teetee maybe a
little too hard on this movie I don't
know so I thought we should just start a
discussion with a change of tone maybe
we can start with point out elements in
this movie that we thought worked things
that pleasantly surprised us and a quick
warning to our viewers just to cover our
bases hear this it's safe to consider
this a spoiler review we will warn you
when we start discussing any big twists
or reveals that come in the mid point or
later in the movie but yeah what let's
start what do we what do we like about
this because I mean I obviously don't
give it a B+ a - at all I think it's
it's more in the B - C plus category but
I will say that I had chia-chu worthy
moments where I was like yes out loud in
the film and a you know if I want to ask
everyone in the cinema that we went last
night opening night was it full no I saw
that the universal like IMAX which I'm
like if fans like to drop a little bit
of extra coin so they can see it like in
a in the big way that the cinema the
filmmakers wanted them to see it and
know it was like main chunk of the
theater middle part filled around the
edges not really saying it's weird yeah
was not as crowded as I was expecting it
to be it seemed like the crowd really
liked it though yeah I don't know I I
agree I think there were some cheer
worthy moments I think going in with
that negative expectation it just made
me enjoy the charming parts of it that
much more one thing I really did like
about this that I wish more super movie
superhero movies did maybe Zack Snyder
just kinda has an instinct for this is
like letting creating these like action
moments that really do pay off
emotionally
like almost like looking at like stunt
set pieces approach you know has seen
Aquaman surf down through the building
on the parademon and land and flip his
hair yeah it's really fun seeing the two
of them work together when he grabs onto
the lasso as well and yang stepping off
that like it's just there's great
teamwork moments that to where they
thought creatively of like how can we
create an image where we see the Justice
League working together and some kind of
creative and a visually interesting way
that's one thing that I really like I
would change the score I get I'd be
closer to mod it's a it's like solid
like in the 70s it's at points it made
me feel like an A+ but overall it's like
in the C plus B minus area I I think it
just kind of comes from the whole being
surprised of how much I enjoyed this
movie there were times when I was
watching I was like I'm waiting for that
moment where it's gonna suck like it's
gonna suck like when you watch Batman V
Superman I'll be honest I think that
thing's a turd I thought really don't
like that movie I watched the extended
edition - not worth the time it really
not worth the time k but with this I was
just like none of that know that's
happening right now I really like seeing
all of the characters interact the
action was pretty amazing throughout and
we'll get to the nitpicks in a second
but no overall I will go see this again
I'm excited too so I can be more
critical about it clean so I can get
like the the fan part of my brain turned
off and really start to like pick it
apart and see what I like oh my I didn't
link my Chi waiting moments though that
I really want to highlight right at the
beginning the introduction of Wonder
Woman you can't have the whole movie
wash over you again and it does a great
job of reminding you that she's such a
powerful stoic like Wonder full woman
and like having you know that the
century over sensory overload of yes she
looks great but then her theme song like
how it's taking on so many so many men
with all of their weapons and she's just
like calm calm calm that for me I got
goose bumps
and then obviously the other moment
which is going into spoiler territory
which involves the flash he realizes
he's not the fastest man oh yes man
alive technically
no holding and like I love that every
time he kind of used the Speed Force
everything else was frozen because
that's how it works and then all the
sudden stings you man's eyes follow him
that was like everyone erupted in the
cinema and that for me was this I got oh
we needed a moment like this and we got
it and it delivered if they've been
waiting for that for years I can't be
proud of that because that was the one
of the best reveals for the movie it was
just at seeing what we'll get into
sports I like the pacing in general of
the movie I thought by the time it led
to the final battle I was ready for it
and yet it was still one of the shorter
movies of this like it was under two
hours yes I was one now so I was like oh
that's right like this feels like a good
time for this movie to be over now
whereas normally there would have been
like five other additional scenes like
we would have probably seen iris West
origins for everybody and I feel like
they kind of cut to the chase with a lot
of the origin stories it was good cuz we
already know them the trailers did a
sufficient job of explaining who you're
gonna get in the movie so I thought the
pacing was really good and I enjoyed the
like little kind of nods to past
franchises we were talking I mean they
had already said that Danny Elfman who
scored the movie was gonna use the
Batman theme but it wasn't like
gratuitous it was just kind of an
exciting fun nod to it and you call it a
fun night I got goose bumps
oh yeah no the Gotham scene in the
beginning really felt like oh this is
like gothic Gotham for ya for just a
second right a little bit felt like kind
of the cold-open of the 1989 Tim Burton
Batman and it's being on a rooftop
Batman just doing what he does best just
kind of foiling some pride it was a
penguin reference in there I love seeing
Green Lantern in there also that entire
scene that idea of using like the story
behind that like no humans came together
at lanterns Amazon's God's demigods
aliens like know this also this is a
serious threat and so like the Justice
League obviously it shows how powerful
they are and it was who that's thing
will get again we'll get into that a
little bit but it's really cool we are
kind of kind of we've talked about some
you've probably already seen the skip
time let's just talk about the big
school it happens right you know okay so
Superman Returns
was a big secret he gets resurrected I
personally I kind of liked this moment
and the movie just it felt very weird
we're all like oh yeah we're gonna do
this right can we do this is this a good
idea what's gonna happen
it's not like the Justice League all
coming together do a weird science
experiment and then it comes up and
they're like oh crap we should've done
this big mistake it felt like there was
a good director up until that point I
thought this story maybe started to
wander a little bit once that happened
they were all like working together to
do this stupid and then seeing them have
to clean up the mess afterwards yeah I
wish they'd explain sorry I wish they
explained what Batman was saying like
they're like oh wait this was used to
bring a cyborg back and he brought him
back to life but a human couldn't handle
I think for what about and I was just
like one extra piece of like where did a
and B make see like how did you do that
but I was like it like they got into him
like you know this is fine I get it I'm
having sense and I like that the
catalyst for bringing Superman back had
to come from barielle and the flash
because like you forget because he's as
rude Miller is kind of playing him as a
goofy kid there he is one of the more
powerful members of the entire like DC
Universe like he's just like basically a
Speed God like and he hasn't he hasn't
harnessed all that yet at this point the
movie but you're in the franchise and
I'm excited for the solo movie even more
after seeing this but it's like yeah
that's when they finally really get to
see a full-bore like this is what the
studio in like and we would be screwed
if he wasn't here this is why he's here
Ezra takes a little bit to grow he grew
on me as the movie went on because a lot
of his specific jokes weren't funny but
he did funny things they were like when
he runs around the Batcave and he's
looking around that's not him just being
like and here's a one-liner and it's
like I think they're like compared to
other superhero movies the humor written
down wasn't very funny except for some
people had some pretty good jokes but
like overall it was just the situation's
that we were getting in I think you had
to do two things at once pull Mary Ellen
he had to be the funny comic relief and
he also had to build his own backstory
yeah say one thing which was like ha
good all this power but I've only ever
pushed someone before and you know that
was funny and then you're like oh yeah
you are not an attack player you're not
an offensive player on the board you're
a defensive player you should be
offensive but he doesn't
I did you get the classic like how do
you get Flash out of a flight you just
have like somehow excuse me my language
but like it just like all the sudden
like it was I'm sorry was always just
like some with his leg like so yeah
someone legs I would like it doesn't
work yeah to me I think like Barry Allen
and flash is kind of the soul of this
movie if it hasn't like he's of all the
Justice League members the one to have
like a true like hero arc like learning
how to be hero what it means to feel
like a hero I you know early on in the
first act it was just like just save one
person you'll know what it feels like
after you save that one person what to
do after that and by the end he's like
oh I'm just gonna be the one who takes
care of the civilian population
I felt like it had like moral redemption
for Man of Steel which they just wiped
out all the civilians like no we're
gonna assign one character just to be
that hero to look after the poor people
cyborg do but it's like they tried to
give him the journey of like I don't
know what I'm doing in this world to
like oh no I'm the man now but it it all
came kind of automatically literally on
like it was automated right yeah and I
think yeah this is a good opportunity to
maybe segue into some of the gripes
because yes this wasn't a perfect film
with it was pleasantly surprising in the
way that was good but yeah I think to me
it had two big errors and things with
the villain will talk about the villain
but I think I was really frustrated with
the way they used cyborg - kind of like
cover all plot holes like his power was
to do everything or technology get there
in time I can make it go that fast okay
you're gonna open a boom tube like like
what's the most easy I think you just
made the engines burn more fuel I don't
know I don't know what you did exactly
he's like yeah once I supercharged I
wish she was on the back and just like I
don't know shooting wrong I don't know
like I don't know what would make him go
faster yeah he's kind of like an
expedition machine who like somehow knew
everything but also his powers worked
like digitally within like the the
digital structure of all technology but
also like hardware wise just like
plugging his wires into a computer
monitor and now he's like basically
Ultron
control over whatever that is it just
felt a little convenient and also
confusing like there was any time we had
to understand what they're gonna do next
if cyborg would just explained something
without us seeing what the objective was
or I didn't understand what was going to
be like oh my gosh were in a really bad
situation water earth are we gonna do to
get out of it he's like death machines
he'll tell us yeah and I think something
I liked about him is that like they
actually added some stakes to his
characters usually it's just like Oh
society won't accept me knowing this
it's like he can't accept himself
because he doesn't know what's happening
to him it's like it's a nightmare and if
he can't if he doesn't like stay on top
of what's happening to him and my
cataloguing it it could take him over
and it could be really safe right woody
sometimes you know you can levitate that
happened to you guys when you hit
puberty right before we start talking
about the villain we actually had a
reaction from another Stardust follower
of ours so his name is Bruce Wayne huh
that's interesting
the Bruce Wayne but he had to take on on
these other things an Superman's return
so let's listen all right
spoiler review just go back from lunch
in Justice League it was fun stronger
than it was okay kind of weak started
off with Batman he was great
Commissioner Gordon he was great JK
Simmons very fantastic Wonder Woman was
fantastic Superman who finally got to
see his superbreath Barry Allen as
Ramona as a flash I love them he was
fantastic he was hilarious overall great
Sai book was kind of weak but other than
that great movie I loved it I loved it
it was great I hear a breeze from Wayne
he's very rich you don't know that he'll
tell you yeah I pick Aquaman didn't get
anything in this movie he's there and he
does have one of the funniest moments
for me in the movie with the lasso truth
that was really I really liked right
first I'm like really poor timing with
all this really like sexist stuff you're
saying like you should really like not
like oh it's just his brain he's just
like literally there's no filter right
now he's saying anything that's coming
to his head I mean when he had that
monologue moment I was like this is the
most he spoke in this entire movie in
the last three second oh it's just for a
joke
mm-hmm but it's like yeah he needed that
he needed need at that moment learning
more about his backstory I felt was
quite rushed and it actually didn't
provide a fun invitation to watch the
standalone movie for me
that wasn't like a great little team his
action makes me want to see it and I
liked how Atlantis looked and Mira being
there for a second I saw someone
complain they're like what it can she do
I'm like I don't know man
the city is under water of course
there's gonna be some kind of magic or
powers or something her making little
bubbles and stuff that was a cool way of
fighting Steppenwolf is immediately
there's gravity now there's pressure now
there's a force that's hitting you and
it's it makes sense I really like how
they they could have used more of her I
feel like she got cut when the mandate
there was a lot more probably Atlantean
content that they could talk in because
it felt like up until that point that
episode of Bojack horseman where it's
all underwater and there's no dialogue
which works really great on boat I get
one my favorite episodes been this I'm
like are they gonna talk like air it is
kind of frightening that win in
Atlantian dies they just kind of like
float there and maybe under the skin
with Scarlett Johansson where she's
she's an alien and I've seen the scene
I've seen that scene yeah just looking
at each other yeah I have to watch the
movie it's like just dead while T is
streamed on my friend about five minutes
oh god that's about right she's an alien
I was like I'm there no I mean I was in
for a car cry tonight anyways well maybe
justify her yes speaking of things that
make you cry
do you guys we should say a couple words
about the villain right I have a big
rant about the villain little room
okay so steppin off yeah he was I think
we did have trouble with just this CGI
villain that we don't really have any
connection to we don't really truly
understand what his motivations are seen
a CGI villain and it not work
Wonder Woman worst part CGI villain Lee
for me oh when he goes into Aries I like
the I like the eye thing in the middle I
think it's just you don't care anymore
and I don't want to keep comparing Thor
to Justice League but when you had
someone like Cate Blanchett playing
hello she's a real person and she amused
it all and you just like oh my gosh
there is a chance I could turn the
corner and see her yeah whereas as soon
as it's a CGI character I'm out man yeah
it's tough because I didn't find there
were moments when the CGI was
distracting for me and I think if I
didn't know any problems with Henry
cavils mustache I wouldn't have actually
noticed it too much I'd be like
something looks weird about him the
whole time that we are talking about CGI
I can shred all day about having a CGI
villain but how how on earth is the
other project that he was on putting a
beard on or a mustache on how is that
harder than CG eyeing it off he's just
to explain for anyone who might know
yeah Henry Cavill had a special contract
with Mission Possible 5:6 where he was
not allowed to shave his mustache at all
that is a fake thing you can do every
movie wants to feel like they're the
most important project on an actor's
slate I'm sure I only noticed it twice I
only noticed it twice how often do you
really look at a person's smile but for
me the CG in this movie I could forgive
it like I got it and I didn't think that
the motivation for the that this villain
was any different from a lot of other
like characters
conquering yeah I know why does why does
Loki one earth I was there was me like I
don't know like waste kycilia Swan
hidden dr. strange if you guys forgot
the name of what magical since crater
was yeah hi Silius and he was like he's
like what do you want is like not dying
kind of not sure and then there's just
this big boot monster in another
dimension that's like wiggling around
and that looked awful like that looked
really bad I didn't find it to be too
distracting because the way they utilize
them so so little in the movie they kind
of just had they mean talked about him
and you got an amazing scene with the
Amazons which we didn't mention but that
whole way that was was a bit sloppy when
they would really fast action and the
horses it kind of just looked a little
distorted as well for me well I think it
was a dice roll right like I think the
craters the film clearly thought well
there's a ton of great beloved superhero
movies that do not have the best villain
so maybe we'll just make this focus on
the team-up part and not because I even
thought the development of stuff like
they could have never shown him until
the end it just explained like this
dudes stealing cubes and then he's gonna
get real powerful maybe like alright I
care as much based on that but I do now
like jaws you kind of get little
fleeting moments of it you know he's
more of a threat because he's not there
yelling at you like when you don't know
it's more intense and I want to say with
the character stuff I feel like really
good characters happened to an average
maybe do what they're good characters
yeah I have a bunch of good characters
in an average movie yeah which is yeah
we've seen that well I mean last week of
these characters we actually asked you
guys to tell us on Stardust which member
of the Justice League you relate to the
most and we have this great reaction
from Nick miss fan and a special friend
in her reaction so being a woman I would
like to say that I identify most with
Wonder Woman
but she's pretty spectacular and can
deflect bullets without even thinking
about it so instinctual so I'd probably
say more like the flash like I feel like
a newcomer like I don't really know what
I'm doing I just get in there and I push
them in and I run away and also I eat a
lot more calories than you would think I
would need so I've got that going for me
with the flash as well thank you so much
for your and you've been great about
like seeing us all kinds of reactions
Nick mist fan so thank you so much and
as reminded the rest of you guys that
you can connect with us on Stardust 2
just click on our download link in the
description below post your reaction on
Stardust to your favorite TV show or
movie and tag us at new rock serves and
that reaction so we can see it we will
feature you on next week's episode and
future episodes that we do this for you
had me take some breath so you know how
all the ocean movies Elevens he's eating
and everything I kind of wish that Ezra
Miller was doing that yeah they boarded
up twice it was kind of a throwaway line
I kind of wish that was like an invested
thing and done so subtly that you barely
realized but like that's a really cool
thing that he has which is not normal
that really defines me as a person
anyway you know it was cut there was one
something it was a thing where he's just
like shoveling burgers into his face
there's he's eating pizza in like the
Batmobile for a second or not that sorry
that the monopoly won't be all that he
has that's silly silly car yeah we're
gonna keep talking about just leave this
whole episode we're gonna talk about
Justice League and our trivia question
moving on to our trivia question is
Justice League themed or DCU themed
passing out our cards here question this
week is I do not know the answer in the
or he might know the answer I don't know
in the opening flashback of Batman V
Superman that shows the murder of Bruce
Wayne's parents what two films were
listed on the movie theaters marquee in
the background in the opening flashback
of Batman V Superman that shows the
murder Bruce Wayne's parents what two
films were listed on the movie theaters
marquee in the back I guess this is the
movie that they were walking out of at
the time when they were about to right
before they were getting killed by the
way that is Jeffrey Dean Morgan aka me
aka the comedian who played Bruce
Wayne's father if he if they did
flashpoint they did Thomas Wayne Batman
that's the perfect person it was
absolutely perfect can you just throw me
a bone a bit well they made up movies
actual movie day I know one of them and
it is an actual movie so I'm assuming
the other one I'm not sure I just need
some I believe it's like fifties or
sixties the one that I know and Batman's
very very old and I can tell you that
like it is thematically connected to the
story I know one that I know I know one
I know one so we have our answers here
my answer down so yeah while our answers
here so yeah we will reveal the answer
of this trivia question at the end of
the show and there will be stakes for
the winners and the losers the winner as
in past weeks the closest answer as
decided by our fabulous judge will do a
sign I will do the sign off goodbyes at
the end of the video and they can kind
of make fun of us and our Twitter
handles however they want and get our
names wrong they can take on a character
named tank as I the loser will have to
read our in other news wrap-up headlines
and be hilarious on the spot oh god who
wants that
Seba we're gonna move on now to and
we're gonna look at we're gonna look at
Justice League by the numbers the number
that I'm most interested in is thirteen
million
now that was Justice League's opening
night box-office profit in Brazil that's
30 million reals it's a Brazilian
currency this was the country's largest
opening for a movie ever now not only is
it super popular there but a part of it
might be because Wednesday was a
national holiday in Brazil however I
think superhero movies huge overseas
success is kind of the bottom line for
these movies these days like even if
American critics don't love them if
millions of people in like Brazil or
China or India watch at the end of the
day it's a win baby the foreign box
office for Batman V Superman and Captain
America's Civil War of Thor Ragnarok
spider-man homecoming they were all
nearly double what they made in the US
interestingly Wonder Woman was one of
the few superior movies to do better in
the US than it did overseas but I think
that was the exception of the rule what
is it about DC's characters who do you
guys think that make them kind of immune
to the world immune around the world the
types of gripes that American critics
might have with it well I mean they're
right they're more iconic like I mean
it's Batman man it's them it's like
they're when you think superhero you
think first usually Superman or Batman
it's it's always either/or then you
think spider-man you go down the list
after that but like you know it makes
sense like if you're a kid you see that
coming out you're gonna ask your parents
oh you want to go see that there's
nearly 80 years of history with these
characters so that you know this was
before Rotten Tomatoes was a thing that
you would punch in and wait on what it's
going to be whether it's worth seeing or
not which there's so much crap a critic
pointed out I don't know if we're we
talking about what some of the problems
with the Rotten Tomatoes
did you critic came out and he said that
like he didn't realize how he was being
scored on Rotten Tomatoes that like
someone will go through the reviews you
guys can correct me of course in the
comments cuz we love doing that but I
but they said that if he didn't use
enough positive words in a review even
if you liked a movie since there weren't
enough positive reviews he would get it
you'd make it rotten on the way by
positive words positive words like loved
it this was good this was blah instead
of being critical of it and actually
coming by the end of being like no I
still enjoyed it see that's funny
because when I do talk about a movie
if I am like it I'll say probably one or
two things that I liked about it but
then also pinpoint the things that I
didn't so like right there we've we've
actually just done it in this episode we
said and shared maybe one possibly two
things that we liked about it but we're
going to spend half an hour talking
about what we didn't like about it so
for this rotten tomatoes if that's your
algorithm that's not really fair at all
because that's not how the average
person or any person talks about the
things that they love unless it's blind
adoration which a lot of DC fans I have
yes yeah wonder if it's like it could be
like a binary thing right like maybe the
way Americans look at things is kind of
binary there's like one or two answers
it's more of like a fixed growth mindset
or something worse I feel like other
cultures are more pluralistic in the way
they look at things and can have more of
a gray area opinion and have a more of a
mixed opinion a truly mixed opinion
about it
she was asking what pluralistic I think
it's a pluralist yeah it means that you
have like you're able to see both sides
of it have an opinion that takes into
account multiple points of view I mean
not everywhere that's true don't comment
in the comment section below because I
read them all and I will come to you
like you were saying earlier saying that
like there was kind of a separate story
of Justice League as it was coming out
of like the product we knew so much
about the production I wonder if like
people who live in China and India and
Brazil aren't paying attention to
whether as ex-knight are stepping down
and joseline's taking over and how that
changes the movie I just don't think
that whole narrative yeah biases people
as much no it's just silly that we knew
so much going into this but like even
like with AZ movie like Star Wars coming
out we know like that Rian Johnson made
some decisions to like do some just some
things different from JJ Abrams but it's
like that's it like why do we know about
all the problems with this shooter this
and this and this and how many writers
they brought in our CGI budget or time
constraints of this studio put on them
it's like I know it's like you don't
want to see how sausage is made like you
don't wanna you don't wanna like I don't
want to know that maybe it's a I wish I
wasn't
yes you can watch Justice League yeah
but also I just had a I had a point
totally blanking right now alright and
there's a lot of cultures or in the
world who definitely do not want to see
how sausage is made because that is not
kosher the point where I feel like a lot
of the movies that we're putting out now
they're actually catering for the
catering for these demographics sure
Doctor Strange they made they made
changes in a particular character so
that it wouldn't offense the Chinese
market and there is a reason why I think
we've got what twelve where we up to now
we just did but the reason is because
they just makes so much money
internationally yeah they don't yeah
they love blockbusters just entertaining
shoot out enjoy movies and it's not even
just sometimes it's just a merchandise
like if there is a chance that a billion
little kids in China will buy a toy as a
result of seeing this movie that movie
will get made and get a hundred fifty
million dollar budget but it's funny
because then you see the opposite side
when they make a movie like the Great
Wall which was made with cooperation
from Chinese video and then they kind of
I think we're intuitive to the fact that
the movie wasn't good and they bailed on
it they were like this movie's not good
it's not good they were actively kind of
like Thai people like don't go see this
movie even though we co-produced it's
like it's fine like it's fine like it's
in China by that you don't need to go
see it well let us move on to another
subject with Justice League I found Ben
Affleck like we're sitting I got a
pretty enjoyable and Batman is just
sleek he got to be a bit more humorous a
bit more of a punching bag and this
would be like I really got asked several
times simply and the butt of jokes yes
their powers I'm rich what which you I
mean you would like I mean if he's
trying to call the shots it's like no
wonder woman just like flicked him and
he just
pancaked on a wall like it's makes sense
and also after I like Lego Batman like
we just made fun of the entire history
of Batman because it's ridiculous if you
can if you can poop on it like a guy
like that it I think good job well every
joke landed
but I do go to ten some are actually
comparing Ben Affleck's Bruce Wayne here
to like the Justice League version of
Tony Stark right at least how Tony Stark
has been used in the Avengers movies I
don't I don't know if that's a fair just
a pigeonholing like that but it does
seem it's not totally certain that Ben
Affleck will be the frontman to the DC
EU that Robert Downey jr. has been to
the MCU right we've been hearing these
news stories ever since stepping down
from director of the Batman over the
summer handing off the project to
director Matt Reeves Affleck has kind of
gone back and forth on whether or not he
will return as Batman and several future
movies recently told USA Today that the
Batman is quote something I'm
contemplating you don't do it forever so
I want to find a graceful and cool way
to segue out of it
so even though it sounds like Affleck
will return he's also kind of indicating
he's not in it for the long haul
bringing up the question of who do you
guys think will take over the role after
him I want you guys to pitch me and I'll
pitch as well what actor do you want to
see take over as the Batman in the
future of the DC EU that's tough because
I know when it was coming out we were
all over the place and when we heard Ben
Affleck look no but it turned out like
he'd I I think he does a good job at
least at Bruce Wayne I really liked his
Bruce Wayne his presence especially in
Batman V Superman I mean that was one of
the highlights for me also the face for
me I feel like for the people the person
bringing everyone together is Wonder
Woman because like that's the one we got
behind like compared to everybody else
got behind sorry oops but for who wait
well now I'm gonna put it over to you
guys because I can't think of anything
and who would you want I was going
through the engineer Mike I'm interested
in who people visualize and if there's a
recurring person and some of the
recurring people on the list was Matt
Bomer who's an actor and Jake Gyllenhaal
was coming up but I can only see them as
the perfect Dick Grayson 15 years ago
I'm like yeah I'm upset that we never
really got a good
Grayson you've not ever for Nightcrawler
sorry
Nightwing Nightcrawler with Jake
Gyllenhaal good lord
like a movie Nightcrawler yeah yeah yeah
yeah like everyone's nerd circuit boards
are fine like no
who was not yeah Australian kid role as
well maybe we should just have a little
bit of a breather on it no okay double
down you have to go back
Christian Bale I think he's done I think
he's like tired I think he's like that's
that's a point though we got him have we
gotta have it real old what he was
playing in the Dark Knight Rises I
wanted wait til Christian Bale gets that
age he's like Matt galley net lighting
guys in the background the set to the
pitch room I know that my last pictures
have been controversial surprising and I
think that you got this is what I like
about Batman and Bruce Wayne
Christian Bale as Bruce Wayne is very
punchable like he's an
sorry he's a jerk he's not nice he is
not your friend so you want like you
like don't like he does a great job of
playing up the Bruce Wayne side of being
kind of like a schmuck and then he's
great as Batman like Bradley Cooper why
not Bradley Cooper moon he's compete
like I mean we saw wedding crashers he
could play and incredibly smash him in
the face type of person and then could
put on the bat suit and be the actual
person that he is and be heroic well
that's okay I wasn't for you it was for
the people out there that I loved so
much I would like him though as one of
the Green Lantern's because there's so
many of them I he could play one of the
20 yeah he could be a good one I'm for
me it's tough because you kind of want a
young they made they played up of how
old he feels at least in this movie and
they grade him up a lot so it like he
looked older and he's been doing this
for 20 years
fun thing to say because that means he
has a whole rose gallery of villains
that you can play around with so it's
tough to pick somebody who's that age
but if they did like a flashpoint story
like they want to do for the flash movie
you could pull this weird switcheroo if
you wanted to because I like jit Jeffrey
Dean Morgan so much and I think he would
play a really good dad and he you play
like
like CGI areas to look like benefit but
it's jeopardy Morgan still blames I
don't know it's a tough it's a tough one
because I honestly now see Ben Affleck
as Batman so if you were to play
somebody or I don't know
damn I think I'm gonna be kicked out
like it's hard I went old I went even
older I old early I want Liam Neeson I
want Harrison Ford I want Bruce Dern
want a wiry old man Batman who is like
what was a Batman Beyond right yeah I
want Terry McGinnis yeah I it's not the
same man it's just I've never seen him
do something like crazy with his acting
ability but he is pretty blue I know
exactly he'd be used to pull it off he's
being very mature it's gonna be someone
that we don't why I don't I personally
wouldn't care if a driver was bad I wish
every single person they casted
superhero roles I go I don't know if I
see that and then they put them in the
car so then I go oh of course that makes
perfect sense it's the costume I'm
trying to think of literally anybody
like anyone at all and I can't I'm told
I mean I don't know every single ones in
like the x-men are like the the I know I
that's what I was thinking someone said
Hugh Jackman and I was like you're gonna
take him from what two decades nineteen
movies he did nine that is insane well
let us know in the comments and on
Twitter and on stardust who you would
like to see take on the role of the Dark
Knight Caped Crusader in the future the
DCU but let us move on so as we said
before you have a villain Stepanovich s
League is probably the biggest gripe
that we had with the film
he's been nicknamed mr. CGI and some
reviews believe the Washington Post
caught him there
he's played by ciarán hinds that's mance
rayder from Game of Thrones so we have
some good acting talent behind it's just
we don't really see his full potential
actually Invictus cosplay on Stardust
had his review of Justice League and
included some thoughts on the villain I
have to say best DC movie they put out
better than Wonder Woman even she was
great in the film Batman was finally
awesome again Superman wasn't this whiny
guy that flash my favorite character in
the film cyborg was awesome not enough
Aquaman the bad guy felt a little bit
disposable and like there wasn't really
any weight to the whole thing yeah I get
it
the world could end but it just didn't
feel like there was enough but still a
good movie yeah I really thought he was
gonna be in all the merchandising yeah
you do make some interesting points
there in terms of the lack of weight and
of the character he did feel a bit
disposable he I think as we were saying
before he is the latest example the CGI
design villains can't really recognize
the threat of because there's really
nothing human I'm so angry I'm so
powerful and you're like are you you're
saying it right I haven't seen we didn't
take down all the Amazons he didn't he
was not slowed down the only thing
disposable were those bug things the
parademons they're gonna correct me in
the comments this magic axe that can
turn people into parademons and they
only show it once yeah why didn't they
should why did they give this gravity of
like taking someone that we meet in the
movie like the janitor at STAR Labs
or the first guy that Batman dispatches
of in what about a green lanten being
take something cool or should show the
whole like transformation or something
it's that it was like yeah this magic
axe does that and hopefully it'll be
around forever but it probably won't you
know what a quick little pitch me for
this it would have been cool when they
kidnapped all those people they were
turning them into parademons when they
weren't giving them answers so at least
he's getting a bigger army that would
have been cool Silas is about to be
Silas Joe Morton loved Joe more and he
was sad where's dad he's about to be
maybe mid-transformation
they get them out of there and they put
them in stasis and then when they try to
test out the mother box it turns them
back and like that would be like I don't
know it wouldn't I don't fit would have
added anything like a little bit or at
least turning those people into them
because you'd be like oh no we have to
move really fast where that had a direct
effect on that but then you know because
of that it was ended up saving the day a
little bit more like this family in the
the only family I mean there were more
people but it's like the only family
that lives in this town what was the
purpose behind this is the thing when
you add faceless nameless people just in
a scenario like unless you have more
character depth or understanding or like
they have a real purpose to be there I
don't care that the flash saved him yeah
I think just I mean I agree I think my
take on it just to go on a miniature
rant here I think CGI villains can work
in theory I think Andy Serkis has shown
us that like you can really create a CGI
character that people totally feel
something for between Gollum and the
Caesar and the plan of the episode
that's not we don't we haven't seen it
enough yet it's possible though I mean
this is would be the guy to do with me
any circus I think the challenges you
just have to put the work in and you
have to like identify what the
characters goals are now we'd brought up
Ultron before as like another example I
personally loved Ultron right did we get
him like we want to see him when he's
not on screen we're wondering what his
latest I he was fun James Spader's voice
work on it was fantastic it was
unfortunate that they killed him up at
the in the movie before like we could
really see the full potential of what
Ultron is in the comics he was an
amazing villain but I think at least we
understand where he's coming from how he
was created why people are afraid of him
and that was CGI he didn't have like a
full human face that we need a locket we
don't need a full human face you don't
necessarily need a great villain but
don't just throw this like CGI villain
that just looks like a computer game
that has no real human needs or once
there's still characters we should still
understand what they want and they
should want it as desperately as the
heroes want it going into the movie like
he was singing no strings on me in such
a haunting sort of way where you're just
like oh this guy's creepy you didn't
really know Steppenwolf going into this
movie with justice Lee because it wasn't
really in the trailers so much you don't
know anything about him and then it's
like yeah
the cliffnotes is true big real bad and
just like what you got from it was he
wanted
he's the Scout of the party that
conquers planets or whatever he failed
the only time he's ever failed
twenty ten thousand years later he's
like and we're good to go Superman
wasn't around for like only around for
like thirty years maybe like three and
like you could have come anytime before
that but anyways like as soon as the old
gods died same thing same thing but I
I'm gonna be honest I really didn't like
Ultron and I wanted to because James
Spader's so much fun actually that's my
least favorite Marvel movie I really
dislike it because it and also mirrors
Justice League a little bit point being
in the middle of it they bring someone
to life using lightning in the middle
with vision and he just shows up he's
super powerful what can he do like I
don't I don't know why vision can walk
through walls I doesn't make if I bring
a robot to life that doesn't mean they
can just do whatever then you guys gonna
say it's this stupid stone in his head
that doesn't explain it doesn't explain
it sorry yeah it's a resonance
frequencies that comics been around for
enough time to explain I'm indifferent
towards Ultron I care James Spader's
great well let us move on to our need to
know lightning round I'm gonna hit you
guys with some rapid fire I'll flick up
questions that you guys have to answer
our lovely fans on Twitter have I don't
know if they're all fans or just people
follow us it's as senesin some questions
that they want to start somewhere deep
critics
I wrote down their names and the
questions here I'm gonna just throw them
at addresses and phone numbers so we'll
come after all of you guys so here we go
okay Maude this is not lightning-fast at
all okay who do you think should play
adult x-23 in the future solo film that
is from at minibrute hey Tommy
at only more supposed to know have we've
reached too much Star Wars there's like
19 Star Wars there's just a lot it's a
long time ago at galaxy far far away I'm
trying to move on from it but yeah yeah
I think we have Sam Incredibles 2 teaser
trailer comes out tomorrow or it may
already be out by the time you're
watching this Oh what hopes do you have
for Incredibles 2 I died I heard Bob you
know Bob Odenkirk signed on to be in the
movie and another I'm blacking I uh
kathleen keener Catherine Keener she
signed on to all right that's I think
it's like might I like in my second
favorite Pixar movie I cannot wait for
what I want more family dynamic it was
the best part of the first year that's a
bit of a stretch but and for me Dom
thebomb.com just want to read it yes
interesting question what does marvel do
that DC doesn't make such a difference
in their reception I don't know if
they're really doing something different
a lot of this is just like a film studio
executives trying to do the same thing
that they've always been doing the
difference is I think Kevin Feige came
in with a very clear strategy that just
that DC and Warner Brothers has been
just trying to play catch-up and they
they haven't had the time to really kind
of come on chime in on someone else's
lightning-round question let's not
pretend like the Robert Downey jr.
playing Tony Stark wasn't the luckiest
casting of all like you're like this man
happens to have turned his life around
at the exact time and is beloved and now
they're all like I mean
yeah well let us take thank you all for
sending those lightning round questions
by the way if you want to further the
future I have some others I didn't get
to but make sure to tweet us next Friday
and we will will answer your questions
the okay so let's move on to the
lightning round videos coming out on the
channel next week guys we have a
breakdown of Justice League coming a lot
of missable details in there I can't
wait to share them all with you guys hey
we also finally have our breakdown of
Game of Thrones season 1 season 1
episode 4 as part of our rewatched
series I know a lot of you guys been
very patient bored some of you not so
patient but either way we will have this
video out
I love the episode we're gonna try to
get through these whenever we can no
[Music]
breakdown of Walking Dead episode 5 my
breakdown breakdown other breakdowns
yeah they keep me working around the
clock Oh what else we got same we got
stuff oh we got a flash breakdown
episode 407 it's fun 1 the seasons real
fun and I like making that show but also
I did a breakdown of the end credits
seams for Justice League and you guys
should go check that out on the channel
right now yeah and last week you
remember Phillips sees some bonus Star
Wars content the pipeline we can't talk
too much about it but we are still
working on them guys that we're very
very very excited about it you're gonna
love them stay tuned
maybe that's related to it ok now comes
the time for our 15-second shout outs
where each of us has 15 seconds to shout
out plug or ramble about anything they
want saying why don't you start ok I'm
gonna go with Bob's Burgers it's on Fox
if you guys aren't watching it you're
messing up it's a delightful animated
series and they're gonna eat a movie in
two years I love it who can't wait
coming over to me I will shout out the
season finale and the entire season of
Nathan for you on Comedy Central I love
the show so much it's so funny I can't
even truly explain I mean because the
premise of the show was already kind of
hard to explain
the final episode I believe I might have
actually plugged this all in my past
episode but the finale specifically it's
like a documentary it's like a two hours
on normaly though it's a half-hour show
it is two hours long and it's just
delightful and heartfelt hilarious to
check it out playing Super Mario I see
but I shout out to my brother who told
me that he's having his very first baby
and I'm gonna be in hot yeah I'm gonna
name it and I'll continue with the
family theme I'm gonna shout out by
nephew James who ended a nine-year hold
out of hating Star Wars by texting me
yesterday I like Star Wars now just
kidding no not really
I like Star Wars now so thank you James
what a weird mind game to play with and
let us return to the trivia question
that we talked about earlier I'm gonna
assign that I'll take time okay so to
remind you guys what the question was in
the opening flashback of Batman V
Superman that shows the murder of Bruce
Wayne's parents what two films were
listed on the movie theaters marquee let
us go down the line and see what
everyone well Eric Excalibur down before
Eric revealed it was like the the decade
was in the 50s because he's written the
mask of zorro and Back to the Future
Part three this is the best one no it's
not the second one well back to the
future part three actually came out in
1870 something I believe right Tommy
bottom line Bechtel top bottom Tommy
Olsson oneth wrote The Mask of Zorro and
deuce Bigalow European gigolo I go from
Maude
it's a wonderful life pretty good and
then not my parents again this is like
what the 17th time is parents of Brad
maybe Mach movie poster being made up
just run idiot I want to play mr. Wayne
at some point in my life it gets good
we're all gonna have a chance to play it
okay okay the answer guys was the Mark
of Zorro and Excalibur yeah I guess in
both cases it's interesting I remember
Excalibur because that is also kind of
the Arthurian legend that like Seven
Samurai was based on when Seven Samurai
was a huge influence according to Zack
Snyder on the story of Justice League
and I guess the Mark of Zorro was also
kind of an influence on Batman just
marking his renegade I was the mask
because he wears a mask I thought that
made more sense cuz Batman doesn't let
her off I mean in the BBS he does Bryan
ppm so judge who is our winner would you
say oh yeah I think we got and our loser
[Laughter]
great at the jokes at the end
oh do our goodbyes but yeah according to
our judge time Tommy you will have to
handle all of our in other news topics
and you're gonna have to be be hilarious
you're gonna have to make some kind of
joke riffing on the riffing on the
details of the native stories you're
gonna be super clever we may we may not
have cool you'll probably be supportive
because we love you bottom line that's
the bottom line of that okay so here we
go a take it away we're waiting for the
prompter to catch up to the Harry Potter
films fantastic beasts and where to find
them announced its title the crimes of
Grindelwald it will star Johnny Depp is
Gellert Grindelwald and Jude Law as
Albus Dumbledore
oh boy johnny depp's really gonna hit
that one out of the park
oh no shouldn't have made me lose the TV
series has been greenlit for multiple
seasons on Amazon wait a second they
don't have TVs on that island
[Laughter]
Mario animated super mario animated
movie has been announced Nintendo is
partnering with illumination the
producing company behind minions and
Despicable Me
that doesn't sound despicable to me and
James Franco will play multiple man in
an upcoming movie he's a mutant from the
Marvel Comics who can create instant
duplicates of himself finally giving
James Franco his dream of giving women
multiple orgasms that would have been
better you should have lost okay well
you know guys thank you for watching
just week's episode need to know Oh
tight clothes a good birthday bash or it
takes tanks talking hey boss not a good
time to have your initials be II am
Maude Garrett mud red Gary yeah that's
not good and tanks dying guys
Tommy Bechtel bottom line is you a
welcome back all right posterior actions
on started some Tagus add new rocks a so
we can see it and maybe to you next
week's video guys wait comment down
below tweet us at new rock stars using
the hashtag need to know like the video
share it around and subscribe to new
rock starts we do dives into stuff you
love guys thank you so much for watching
[Music]